HOLDING THE GUN.
YOU MIGHT CALL IT THE ULTIMATE
VANITY PROJECT.
OUR GUEST IS A FORMER AGENT.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS.
THE TECHNOLOGICAL WALL, THE
VANITY PROJECT.
YOU HAVE SPENT YOUR LIFE
POLICING OUR BORDERS.
DO WE NEED PHYSICAL WALL, AN
ACTUAL WALL?
>> WELL, TUCKER, I HAVE TO SAY
THIS IS PERSONAL.
I HAVE WORKED IN MEXICO.
I HAVE WORKED ON THE BORDER.
BORN AND RAISED THERE.
I WAS ATTACKED AND AGENT
CEPATA LOST HIS LIFE WHILE WE
WERE IN ASSIGNMENT IN MEXICO.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS REAL AND
THE CRISIS IS REAL.
THE BORDER WALL IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED.
THIS IS A PHYSICAL BARRIER
THAT WILL HELP OUR BORDER
AGENTS DOWN THERE.
HELP THEM JUST LIKE THE OTHER
TECHNOLOGY WOULD HELP THEM.
THE DRONES, THE SENSORS.
ALL THE OTHER TECHNOLOGY THAT
COMES ALONG THE BORDER, THE
BORDER WALL IS JUST ANOTHER
TOOL THAT WILL HELP THEM DO
THAT.
IT'S MUCH NEEDED SO THEY CAN
FOCUS ON THE AREAS WHERE THAT
TRAFFIC IS GOING TO BE
INFILTRATED TO.
>> Tucker: SO IN THE
SHOOTING YOU REFERRED TO, YOU
WERE HIT THREE TIMES.
YOU WERE SHOT THREE TIMES BY A
MEMBER OF A MEXICAN DRUG
CARTEL.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU, AS
SOMEONE WHO WENT THROUGH THAT,
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE WHEN YOU
HEAR MEMBER OF CONGRESS,
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS SAYING
THERE IS NO CRISIS AT ALL AND
WE'RE IMAGINING IT AND IN FACT
IT'S RACIST TO SAY THERE IS A
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> THE CRISIS IS REAL.
I LIVED IT AND WORKED IT.
ESPECIALLY THE RACIST COMMENT
IS UNREAL.
MEXICO NOW IS LOOKING TO START
TO CONTROL THEIR OWN SOUTHERN
BORDER BY SENDING THEIR OWN
FEDERAL TROOPS DOWN TO THE
GUATEMALA AND BELIZE BORDER
BECAUSE THEY'RE FEELING THE
IMPACT OF THE IMMIGRANTS
COMING THROUGH THEIR COUNTRY.
SO ARE THEY GOING TO BE RACIST
AS WELL?
SO IT'S ABSURD TO THINK THAT
IT MAKES IT A RACIST STATEMENT
BECAUSE, OR IT MAKES YOU A
RACIST BECAUSE YOU WANT A
WALL.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IS
IMMORAL.
WHAT IS IMMORAL IS THE
EXPLOITATION OF THE ASYLUM
LAWS.
CONGRESS NEEDS TO SHUT DOWN
AND REDO THE ASYLUM LAWS AND
LEGISLATION.
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
IF AN ADULT PERSON COMES IN TO
THE COUNTRY WITH A MINOR CHILD
AND PRESENTS THEMSELVES TO THE
BORDER PATROL, AND TURNS
THEMSELVES IN SEEKING ASYLUM,
IF THAT ADULT PERSON HAS A
CRIMINAL HISTORY AND IS KNOWN
TO HAVE A CRIMINAL HISTORY,
BORDER PATROL WILL HAVE TO
STILL ADMIT THAT PERSON IN
WITH THE CHILD.
EVEN THOUGH THAT PERSON IS NOW
INADMISSIBLE TO COME IN THE
COUNTRY, WE HAVE TO ALLOW THEM
TO COME IN WITH THE CHILD TO
SEEK, TO WAIT FOR THE ASYLUM
HEARING TWO OR THREE YEARS
FROM NOW AND WE'LL NEVER HEAR
FROM THAT PERSON.
MAYBE THAT ADULT PERSON IS OR
NOT THE PARENT OF THE CHILD.
WE'LL NEVER KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
TO THE CHILD AS WELL.
SO THERE IS A REAL CRISIS AT
THE BORDER HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW.
>> Tucker: HAVE YOU SPOKEN
TO THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI OR THE DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS AS THEY FORMULATED
THEIR POSITION IN THE DEBATE
OVER THE BORDER WALL?
HAS ANYONE TALKED TO YOU?
>> NO BUT I WOULD LOVE TO.
THERE IS A MAJOR DISCONNECT
BETWEEN WASHINGTON AND
CONGRESS AND WHAT IS GOING
DOWN IN REAL LIFE AND THE
BORDER.
IT WOULD BE SO EFFECTIVE TO
HAVE THEM JUST AT LEAST GO
DOWN THERE AND NOT JUST FOR
THE PHOTO OP OR FOR A
TEN-MINUTE WALK WHERE THERE IS
AN ACTUAL WALL THAT ACTUALLY
WORKS THANKS TO JIM ACOSTA.
BUT TO ACTUALLY LEARN WHAT THE
REAL CRISIS IS DOWN THERE.
NOT TODAY, TUCKER.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR
DECADES.
THIS IS JUST NOW THE INFLUX.
I TALKED TO THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS AND THEY TELL ME THEY
WANT THIS RESPONSE TO GO
FORWARD WITH THE WALL.
THEY ARE SO AFRAID IF THIS
DOESN'T GO THROUGH THEY CAN'T
IMAGINE THE INFLUX OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS GOING THROUGH
BECAUSE THEY'LL SEND THE WRONG
MESSAGE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW YOU FEEL.
IF I WAS SHOT THREE TIMES BY A
DRUG CARTEL AND WATCHED MY
PARTNER MURDER AND SOMEONE
CALLED ME A RACIST BECAUSE I
WANTED A WALL, I DON'T KNOW
HOW YOU REMAIN SO CALM BUT I'M
IMPRESSED THAT YOU DO.